كنت في المنزل على مكتبي ولاحظت
إشعارًا على جهاز iPhone الخاص بي لطلبات السحب
من إحدى
مؤسساتي المالية ، واعتقدت أنه من الغريب
أنني لم أقدم طلب سحب ، ثم
نظرت إلى هاتفي ورأيت أنني
قد فعلت ذلك  لا توجد خدمة ، لقد سُرقت مليون دولار في
تلك الليلة ، تم تضمين
صندوق تقاعدي الجامعي لابنتي ،
تخيل أن أفحص هاتفك يومًا ما
وأدركت أن حسابك المصرفي قد
استنفد وأن مدخراتك
سُرقت ، وهذا ما حدث لروب روس
الذي كان ضحية  نوع من القرصنة
يسمى sim swapping sim swapping هو
طريقة جديدة للمحتالين للاستيلاء بشكل أساسي
على الهاتف الخلوي للضحية أثناء
نومهم لم أكن أعرف أن هذا
ممكن لم أكن أعرف ما يمكن أن يحدث
في تلك اللحظة أدركت ذلك  لقد كنت
أتعرض للهجوم نظرًا لأن
بطاقات SIM الموجودة في الهواتف المحمولة تستهدف بشكل كبير بطاقات SIM الموجودة في الهواتف المحمولة ، فإليك
الطريقة التي يعمل
بها المتسلل باستخدام الرشاوى أو الحيل بطريقة أو بأخرى في الحصول
على ممثل خدمة العملاء
من مزود الخدمة الخلوية لإجراء  sim swap
عبر الهاتف ، مما يتيح للمتسلل
الوصول إلى رقم هاتف الضحايا من
هناك والذي يفتح الباب أمام
الحسابات المصرفية للبريد الإلكتروني للضحايا والتطبيقات الأخرى
، يمكن أن تستغرق العملية بأكملها
ما يصل إلى 20 دقيقة وتأخذ ضحية
من الحصول على مليون دولار في  نقودًا
حرفيًا لم يتبق لي سنت واحد خوفًا ، لقد
كان خوفًا تامًا من البحث عن مساعدة ،
ذهب روس إلى مجموعة تسمى رد فعل
فرقة عمل خاصة من
الوكالات الحكومية والفدرالية المحلية التي تكافح الجرائم الإلكترونية ،
وهناك العديد من السبل التي نتخذها
عندما نحقق في مبادلة sim
أولاً ، من خلال تتبع محققي الهاتف الذين
قاموا بتوصيل استخدام الهاتف في
هذه الجريمة بحالات مبادلة sim أخرى ،
لا يمكن للاحتيال أن يعمل بدون شخص
يحمل هاتفًا فعليًا في
الاتصال بنا  كان من الواضح أن
الهاتف المستخدم كان في مانهاتن ، لذلك على
الرغم من أن لدينا سجلات خلوية
تشير إلى مانهاتن التي يبلغ نصف قطرها ثلاثة أميال ،
إلا أنه يمكن أن يصل عدد سكانها إلى ثلاثة ملايين شخص ،
ولكن مع جميع الأدلة الأخرى
التي تشير إلى وجودها ، كان من الواضح
أنها كانت موجودة  حقيقة أن Trulia التي كانت
تمتلك تلك
الخلايا الدبقية الحقيقية هي Nicolas Trulia ، أحد رواد
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الذي كان وقت
الهجوم يبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا فقط ، نظرنا
إلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي Truglio بعد السرقة
من Rob Ross الذي كان يعرف أنه يرتدي
ملابس باهظة الثمن
صور مجوهرات باهظة الثمن على طائرات خاصة
تشرب شمبانيا باهظة الثمن ، كان من
الواضح لنا أنه كان يعيش بما
يتجاوز إمكانياته في أي وظيفة مشروعة وهو
علم أحمر كامل بالنسبة لنا.
منظر قاتل
تمكنا من طرقه على ذلك الباب مع
عدم علم جوليا حتى وصلنا إلى هناك ،
تقول الشرطة إنها فتشت
شقة Trulia ووجدت دليلًا على أنه كان على اتصال
لقد قام بالمقايضة التي أنشأها
شخصًا لكونه عبقريًا ماليًا
ثريًا حصل بطريقة ما على أمواله من
خلال الاستثمارات ، لكن عندما كشفنا
كل ما يتعلق به كان
كذبة Truglio تم اتهامه في عدة
تهم بما في ذلك جرائم الكمبيوتر
بقصد  احتيال دفع بأنه غير مذنب
ورفض محاميه التعليق
على القضية أثناء
استمرارها.
الفشل في
الشركات الكبيرة إذا كان بإمكانك خداع رشوة أو
إقناع شخص ما بفعل شيء
سيء حيث تكمن
المسؤولية ويجب محاسبته ، لا أعرف
ما إذا كنت سأسترد كل أموالي ، أعتقد
أن هذا نوع فريد من
هجوم الاختراق الذي لا يتطلب الكثير من
التطور يمكن للأطفال الذين يبلغون من العمر عشر سنوات إجراء
مبادلة SIM غير قانونية ، وليس هناك الكثير مما يمكننا
القيام به لحماية أنفسنا من
تبادل بطاقة sim ، ما يمكننا القيام به هو  حماية
أنفسنا من الضرر الذي
يمكن أن يفعله هؤلاء المحتالون بمجرد أن يتحكموا في
حساباتنا ،
سيطلب منك كل حساب لديك نوعًا من
الاسترداد وما لا تريد استخدام
هاتفك
الذي يقولونه باستخدام بريدك الإلكتروني للتحقق
تعد حساباتك خيارًا أفضل من
استخدام هاتفك ،
نوصي أيضًا بأن
لا يستخدم مدير كلمات المرور نفس كلمة المرور مرارًا
وتكرارًا لأنه من المحتمل
أن يكون الأشخاص هناك على دراية
بكلمات المرور التي استخدمتها في عمليات
اختراق sim السابقة.  تم الإبلاغ عن جميع
شبكات الهواتف المحمولة الأمريكية الرئيسية
عندما تم اختراقه ، كان روسلين يستخدم
خدمات الهاتف من الشركة الأم لشركة AT&T CNN ،
يقاضي روس شركة AT&T على أمل
استرداد أمواله.
تعمل مع
جهات إنفاذ قانون الصناعة والمستهلكين لدينا
لوقف ومنع هذا النوع من
الجرائم ، كما رددت الشركة صدى الخبراء في
حث الشركات والمستهلكين  أضاف المتحدث أن عدم
استخدام أرقام الهواتف المحمولة
كمصدر وحيد للأمن
والمصادقة ، فمن المؤسف
أن السيد.  عانى روس من هذا لكننا
عارضنا مزاعمه ونخطط
لدحضها في المحكمة
[موسيقى]